pourtant je sais quel est cet endroit
[Musique]
les gardiens du temps sont les rois du
cirque
et le clown y jouent leur rôle à la
perfection
des métaphores en pagaille c'est
magnifique ça vous donne l'air encore
plus malin je suis malheur mais je sais
ok ok signé pour valider tout ce que
vous avez dit dans votre vie
cette action y compris ça
[Musique]
nous produit jour la fluidité en
ramassant le tesseract vous avez altérer
la réalité je veux que vous nous aidiez
à y remédier
pourquoi moi il se trouve que le point
de vue de locquirec inimitable j'aurai
une arme
vous croyez vraiment ce variant loki
forte heureusement ils croyaient en lui
même pour nos 2
je suis très touché
vous sembliez vous imaginez
pouvoir manipuler
ce tee longueur d'avancé sur nous
tu as confiance n'est pas votre coin
forme espace
vous pouvez me faire confiance l'eau qui
j'ai passé en revue le moindre moment de
votre vie passée vous avez littéralement
travaux semblables chaque fois que
c'était possible je n'ai qu'à pas
recommencer